so UFO sightings why do UFO sightings
based on you know what you read about
tend to increase during times of War you
know oh that's very simple because there
are lots of things flying in the air you
know there were astronomers in Ukraine
that reported about seeing dark objects
at distance of maybe 10 miles
that are the size of 10 meters and
they're moving at 15 kilometers per
second like
10 miles per second not per hour per
second and that's faster than the Escape
speed from the earth okay they were
reporting about it they got it wrong the
distance was I think wrong and because
they would not be dark such objects
moving so fast would create a fireball
like a meteor so if you bring the
distance down by a factor of 10 or 100
you end up with perhaps artillery shells
perhaps bullets perhaps even
flies you know passing in front of their
camera
there are many more flying things in a
battlefield and that's why you get
confused so that's what I think is the
reason I feel extremely paranoid I want
to be extremely paranoid I want your
feedback on this so like this article
here says Ukraine's Astron astronomers
say there are tons of UFOs over Kiev
right okay right so to me you know if if
let's let's paint the government to be
who we think it is right they think you
don't have to know everything they think
they know what's best they think it's
better you not know all the stuff about
aliens okay so there's two positioning
here one is when you read about Richard
bird Admiral Richard bird when he goes
to Antarctica and these two you know uh
whatever you want to call it take
control the plane and they land and they
say look Our concern is right now uh you
know too many Americans are humans are
playing with fire with the nuclear bomb
and all this other stuff this is a
concern of ours what are you guys doing
on the other side right is what he's
talking about so the concern is they
want to prevent one argument is they
want to prevent from war taking place
because some of them live here they live
in the crust or they live on the hollow
side of Earth the other part for me is
which is a paranoid way of thinking
about it is when there's war going on
and there's a lot of issues going on
politically the best way to distract
people is say hey look I just saw an
alien while over here I'm robbing you or
I'm taking stuff away from you so this
is also a great tactic to distract
people and start focused on Aliens which
of those two do you think is more
credible oh the second but I I do think
that I have a problem with helicopter
parenting okay I don't think the aliens
are helicopter parenting us that's
unlikely because we are not that
important we're not their kids uh at
most they can just ignore us you know
um
but they started the journey to Earth
before humans existed on Earth they
didn't have us in mind we are not that
significant we keep thinking that
everything is centered on us you know
when you go out to a date you keep
thinking oh you are special that
everyone but then you realize after a
time that you know you're not that
special okay and that's what I think we
our starting point should be we it's a
sign of arrogance of us to think there
is nobody out there and if there is
someone out there they're really trying
to fix something here on Earth to help
us
you know I don't believe in uh
helicopter parenting I believe in
gadgets that may have been sent in our
Direction possibly with artificial
intelligence but they pursue their goals
okay and we need to figure out what
their goals are rather than assuming
that it's about us we are not that
significant let's be modest the cosmic
play is not about us so you think the
UFO citing increase could be a
distraction from the government working
on other things like yeah for example
the Ukrainian astronomers were able to
identify the distance to one object that
was very high you know like tens of
kilometers and that happens to be a
satellite and probably a satellite that
monitors what happens in the battlefield
so obviously there are lots of drones
there are lots of
satellites looking over this battlefield
that many of us are not aware of you
know the US government operates of
course intelligence operations around
this battlefield to help the Ukrainian
people you know that I'm sure is the
case so the ukrainians are not really
aware you know citizens or even the
military probably is not aware of
everything going on and they would see
things and of course some people might
say it's a UFO but it's really it's not
an unidentified object it's an object
that some people in Washington DC know
exactly what it is because you know they
operate it so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]